when you've got if a woman has a high
value man she's gonna cheat with someone
close because it's not you have to be in
the circle to kind of be around anyways
you're gonna have to look around at
who's available and it's going to be
someone close it kind of feels a bit
vindictive you know because when men if
if men go and cheat you know the the the
men that go and cheat they'll maybe go
outside of the circle far far away where
we're with the women it's very it's not
because at all
every question would you rather him [ __ ]
a stranger your best friend no I'm just
saying with the with it being worse for
more vindictive for women to find
someone around because it's like okay
it's might be being bubbling and the
tension was there and then it happened
but the guy you're saying he left town
went town over town and tried to look
for somebody that you won't find out
like that's right
consideration yeah the reason why I said
why is consideration more forgivable
than like a happy accident because
you're not that's not a happy accident
that's literally someone in this case
said training her kids so this guy is
all right yeah
and him and he's got she's got the balls
basically to get involved with this guy
who's around his kids maybe like him and
trust him okay
like put yourself if all right you have
a boyfriend you're really into her
husband let's say husband he cheats it's
just a one-time thing no feelings
involved this girl just threw it on him
and he he went with this he's he's a
dude okay thought she was hot that's it
never talk to her again or he screwed a
girl he has feelings for
yeah
um probably the one that he doesn't have
feelings for because it's like why are
you throwing it away like if you had
feelings or something it's like okay
fine act on your feelings maybe some
random person that's that feels a bit
worse to me really that's interesting
for me like I would if it's just a
random girl like whatever like I can get
over it
I don't know because right if you have
food I don't know if you have feelings
for them it's like okay there's reason
behind it but you're gonna do that for
no reason that just seems this one has
betrayal and public disrespect yeah yeah
if you know what I noticed women that
have high value men once they've had
kids with high value men they will sleep
they have the same mating strategy as
men they will sleep with young guys that
make them feel attractive he doesn't
have to have money Kim did it Madonna's
doing it she's doing it once they have
their kids and they've got the father of
their child and he's high value then she
goes back to just whoever I want yeah
and that's the kitchen they become just
like men yeah so that's like like what
do you think women value more in money
or looks feelings remind me how a man
makes them feel and when he spends a lot
of money on you you feel expensive
okay one or two I didn't say feelings
to the question I asked money or looks
I'm always gonna say the way they feel
uh if you're in trouble okay okay the
next money your looks
uh so why they cheat basically right no
no I'm saying what do you think women
prefer
I guess money these days money you think
what do you think money oh it looks I I
think looks too actually it looks for
sure you know you you know how you know
that's Cap City now you know that's cap
do you know that boy that um J house
says wait wait he's talking about I'm
ugly man making pretty money that they
they don't look like people still
probably getting girls because he was a
Trapper because you're trapped on the
lifestyle that he portrays like oh but
even if you may not have money come with
it that portrays
money regardless of the money
okay this is this is my theory I'm this
is I don't I don't know if this is facts
or whatever but I feel like if a girl is
dating a guy and she's not like
genuinely attracted to him she'll cheat
yeah
she's still gonna cheat if that guy
comes along and he's that big yeah
for man with that has investment because
like if a girl values and looks more
chances are that something that she
feels more attractive when she's with an
attractive man if she values money more
she already knows she's attractive she
wants lifestyle more so that's why
pretty girls go for rich men
yeah but I just I just think the more
like like genuine connection comes more
from looks but if it's but if it's money
like I've just noticed that girls seem
to be using him more or she's not really
attracted to him and like doesn't rate
it looks also using someone look at that
Uncle in your DM that is sending you a
Madness and he's a prince of somewhere
and he's saying he'll he'll buy this and
do all this kind of stuff here and look
how you're treating him compared to this
person that you feel like let's say
eight let's say eight exactly let's say
you girls like AJ same way that girls
were actually over AJ right if he didn't
have the money right yeah they'll pick
that over this Uncle sending you a
random DM promising you however many
however much money and stuff like that
so I think if the woman has her own
money as well mine doesn't even matter
yeah or just even your own values I'm
not gonna lie the money won't matter the
money always matters in some degree
no I think no I don't I don't believe
this guy's jobs to look good that's the
woman's job to look that's why it's so
hot when they do look I kind of disagree
with that one still as as a
self-respecting as a guy you definitely
need to keep yourself up in maintenance
oh yeah I'm saying that but I'm saying
that looks like the levels are different
in regards to look so the importance of
you don't have to do too much compared
to the females yeah and we can
supplement in other areas right so
that's what I say about that so you can
be funny you can be like yeah stuff like
that women can't be funny we can but we
we don't if we're if we're not attracted
to us our funniness is not going to make
you more attractive yeah funny I think
and then it does no I just think money
is the man's makeup that's it
muscles what do you think more or even
humor and stuff like even if a guy is
ugly and he's funny but then if a guy is
like oh yeah funny
signals social status and women are very
attracted to status like why do you
think what do you think a check mark
does wonders on Instagram the confidence
how many how many ugly guys
ugly I've gotten attractive girls with
that check mark
I don't think so because your status is
intangible it's imaginary but with money
it means that you've actually put in
some work and you've got somewhere it
doesn't mean money alone can give you
status because you could just win the
lottery or you could just you know get
one here but I don't think status alone
is enough you know what's interesting
women are more attracted to men that
have made money lost it and then made it
again yeah
there was some like poll done where it's
like do you would you rather have a guy
that like made money lost it and then
made it again or a guy that just like
totally grew no no slowly like grew
money over time or something it was
something like that but women picked
number two because we're attracted to
Risk Takers Risk Takers implies that
they're able to
um recalibrate yeah and protect in the
future yeah
why are you laughing
oh [ __ ] women women make so much
um like decisions based on how they feel
yeah at that time yep that is just
hilarious
designed by God I just hope it's is it
working for you guys as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible